Before you can do any
mapping applications,
you need to get a key that gives you
access to the google maps android API.
This is pretty easy to do, but
it involves taking a few steps out of
Android studio for the time being.
You're going to be working in terminal.
So as you can see,
I've opened my terminal here.
The first thing you need is
the SHA1 fingerprint for your app.
Google maps uses this as a way
to identify your application, so
it can give your app good service.
This fingerprint is a machine readable
attribute of a certificate and
a certificate is a way of
determining that your app is real.
Just like in the real world,
a certificate is a sign of an authority,
where you can call upon a third party
to certify that you are who you
say you are.
Now we're just going to use a debug
certificate for this as it's easier for
learning purposes.
The debug certificate is
issued to you by yourself.
Now later, if you want to release
your app to the play store,
you'll need a publication certificate
which is verified by Google.
If you want to do that,
follow the instructions on
the developer website linked below.
The first thing that you'll need to do
is to locate your key store file for
debugging using the terminal.
It's called, imaginatively enough,
debug.keystore.
On a Mac or Linux,
it's at cd ~/.android.
So note that when you put a dot in front
of a folder like this it's usually
hidden so just know that
you may need to unhide it.
If you're using Windows it'll be at
c:/user/ your user name /.android.
Remember it could also
be hidden on windows.
This is the directory that
contains the debug.keystore
nad I can use this to
get the fingerprint.
And I'll show you how to do that next.
The command to get the certificate
is the keytool command.
And the keytool command,
you tell it your keystore.
And you can see the keystore
location is .android/debug.keystore.
You also just give it an alias.
I'm calling it the androiddebugkey.
And the password and username is just
android when you're using debug.
So, when I press Enter, you'll see my
SHA key is listed in the certificate.
The certificate fingerprints are here,
MD5, SHA1, and SHA256.
So, just keep track of the SHA1 key.
I would just recommend leaving the
terminal window open because you will be
needing that data in a moment.